genton adore les faits qui font de la
télé réalité contrait à son tableau de
chasse plusieurs stars du genre
tableau de chasse c'est moche ça
d'ailleurs
écrit ça alors déjà delphine ne fait pas
de télé réalité non ensuite et je
rappelle que guillaume genton c'est un
gentleman la pac tableau de chasse au
tueur avec exactement bravo exactement
non et j'ai eu une histoire et quelques
années avec l'équipe
non non mais on va pas avoir des
problèmes tous les soirs c'est bon c'est
bon esprit alors donc si vous avez une
très belle histoire belle histoire on
risque de court tous les cas le
reconnaît oui oui on la connait c'est
tout chaud connaît moins en version wii
que j'aime bien je sais
c'est passé tout veiller pas que sartre
à bout ici et donc elle a fait la tv
réalité oui il ya longtemps bien
longtemps malgré une elle avait relaté
les taux courts brune aussi en basse et
ben voilà c'est vous bon bah c'est bon
alors
c'est afida turner